welcome back to part two your second
lesson of the seven lessons if you
haven't yet subscribed to this channel
communication coach I encourage you to
do so at some point in the process
because in addition to this free course
there's lots of other material on the
channel and I keep adding more material
every week so let's jump into lesson
number
[Music]
two in our first lesson we looked at
long- windedness and in this one we're
going to get after how per form a
concise overall message so concise tip
number two is keep the overall message
tight Mark Twain once joked I didn't
have time to write a short letter so I
wrote a long one instead and the point
he's making there in a humorous way is
that it takes time to whittle down your
message to the essence it's much easier
to just be
long-winded but everybody appreciates a
concise message whether it's a
presentation a meeting a talking turn
and a conversation or your elevator p
people want you to finish on time and
they want you to wrap it up I put
elevator pitch in quotations because
first of a don't like that phrase but
also it signals that it's a message that
you have to finish in about the time you
have in an elevator ride so you have to
express what you do or what your
organization does and how they add value
in a very short amount of time strategy
number one is skip to the heart of the
message that's the best way to compress
your overall message skip the Preamble
the qualifications the back story don't
think out loud just bottom line it
that's a picture there of a golden
retriever I have a little golden re
retriever puppy right now which reminded
me of her so what's the heart of this
message so I was driving around the
other day doing you know errands and
whatnot I saw a car go by that looked
just like yours at least it looked like
your car to me do you drive a Toyota
anyway I saw this card it made me think
of you you know what it may have been a
Honda not a Toyota their SUVs look so
similar long story short it made me
think of you and that's why I called
it's been too long we'd love to get
together we were wondering if you'd like
to bring your family over next weekend
it might have been a
Subaru so if you had to whittle this
down to the very core part of this the
part that you absolutely want the other
person to hear out of this message what
would it be if it were me I would say
it's been too long we'd love to get
together we were wondering if you'd like
to bring your family over next weekend
if you got off the phone it didn't say
these three sentences I think that you
probably would have said oh I never
really said what I wanted to say if you
take away the rest of it you have the
heart of the message the opposite is not
true if you took away these three
sentences and you were just left with
the rambling about the car the message
would make very little sense and so you
want to make sure you focus on what the
person needs to know and we do that by
using need to know versus nice to know
thinking to get to the heart of the
message what does a person absolutely
need to know know and what's just nice
to know little details that you could
leave out and still communicate your
message effectively and if the person is
let's say they're stressed for time or
your reception is not good on the phone
what would you focus on that's generally
when you're going to get down to the
heart of the message strategy number two
is to make your point and then zip it so
you state the heart of the message end
your talking turn by literally closing
your mouth and give the other person a
chance to talk look for those head nods
and other non-verbal cues that shows
that that person is reading and you stop
talking after just a few
sentences so let's say you're having a
Q&A with somebody and they ask you have
you contacted the meeting planner yet
what would you cut out of the answer to
get to the heart of the message and then
zip it then close your mouth here's the
answer no not yet I still have to figure
out what we need from her I've got a
call scheduled with the children
Ministry leader but I have to see if
that call is actually going to happen
I'm also waiting to hear back from the
musicians if our first choice for music
is available then it'll shape the rest
of the program there are lots of balls
in the air right now but we'll get there
I just didn't anticipate so many loose
strings you know that would still be
loose at this point so remember this is
a very direct question have you
contacted the meeting planner yet this
is a yes or no if it were me I would cut
almost all this to make sure I express
my main point and then zip it no not yet
I still have to figure out what we need
from her and this leaves room for the
conversation to continue so now it's
their turn to talk and hopefully you're
noticing these non-verbal cues that
signal you to stop a lot of times people
misread this the person says okay all
right and they're nodding and we might
think oh they really like what I'm
saying I'll keep talking but it means
just the opposite this is your signal to
stop strategy number three finish just
under time in many situations like a
meeting you'll be given a certain amount
of time for that work and you want to
wrap it up under the time limit so if
you have an hour wrap that meeting up in
55 minutes nobody's going to complain if
you have a 30-minute presentation finish
it in 28 minutes if you ask somebody for
five minutes of their time only use four
develop a habit of getting under time
instead of going over time and a lot of
people go over time especially in
meetings and presentations and
conversations like this in fact you
might take a great speaker that you
think is amazing and she's just crushing
it at the 25 minute Mark and she's
supposed to finish at 30 minutes and she
doesn't and now she's 35 or 40 45 and
now a speaker that was
amazing a few minutes ago is now 10 or
15 minutes over time and they're boring
everybody to death you do not want to be
that kind of Communicator you want to
finish just under time respect people's
time and they will start to think of you
as a concise
Communicator so keep your overall
messages tight to do that you want to
skip to the heart of the message I think
most conversational messages can be
delivered in about two or three
sentences only once you make your point
zip it and give the other person a
chance to talk that'll develop into a
conversation and when you have some kind
of time limit that you're shooting for
finish just under time your first task
is to apply this in conversations
stories and any kinds of meetings that
you have coming up in the near
future up next we're going to work on
concise and clear sentences and I look
forward to seeing you in that
lesson